today we're talking about io ai and
choosing your own journey to the cloud
i'm carter morgan and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news the 2021 google
i o developer event will be held
virtually from may 18th to 20th
connect with developers from around the
world at this year's virtual google i o
for thoughtful discussions hands-on
learning with google experts
and a first look at our latest developer
products don't forget to register and
check out the i o 2021 puzzle
machine learning plays a crucial role in
surveilling and measuring the
biodiversity of wildlife in a
non-invasive way
on this episode of people and planet ai
we show you how to create an image
classification app for wildlife camera
tracks with the help of dataflow and
google cloud's ai platform unifi
watch to learn how you can create an
application that tracks wildlife
biodiversity
rather than wait for budget alert emails
you can use programmatic budget
notifications to send budget updates to
your favorite comms channels like slack
check out this guide on how to set up a
cloud function and transform your budget
notifications into code
once you're working with code there's no
limit to what you can do
choose your own cloud adventure you get
to make the choices for the engineers at
the new startup eat and run that
specializes in pairing runners with the
best food options while they're on the
go
now that the company has gained national
attention and user traffic is
skyrocketing
they need your help to succeed should
they scale up their back end services or
speed up the delivery of their assets
the choice it's up to you if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you